I got to play a ton of destiny 2 on PC
at 4k 60 frames per second and I
probably won't be going back to the
console version just being able to act
and react at a silky smooth frame rate
is a game changer for me and playing the
console version afterward felt pretty
choppy on top of that the keyboard and
mouse controls were on point you know
checking corners turning around using
precision weapons is much more enjoyable
with a mouse and you'll see in this
gameplay clip from a couple crucible
matches I was able to capture but it's
all that enough if you already spent
hours on end and the console versions
let us know what you think all right
let's get this some gameplay
[Music]
zone a loss
three minutes left don't see capture
zone advantages your don't be lost
zone a captured you have zone advantage
don't seed lock zone a lost you captured
Zone C you have advantage Zone B lost
that shut them down
don't seed lock it's a power play
get those zones back 30 seconds
fight on
you captured Zone C
supremacy defeat your opponent and take
their crest
[Music]
[Music]
2:01
drinking numbers Guardian excellent yes
you take them like a treat you have my
respect hunter
that's why we have piety
glory glory is yours
control I know you can fight but can you
hold territory
[Music]
don't be captured power-play keep the
pressure on zone' lost
Zone C captured Zone B capture zone
advantage is yours
you captured Zone C power play keep the
pressure on Zone B lost by a team that
fights together stays together
[Music]
don't see captured you have advantage
well executed
those control targets eliminated nice
work
[Music]
you